[Music]
your users know that the word install
means that it's software that's meant
for their device and you want to meet
your users expectations so that's what
you see there on the right an app that
launches from the home screen and is
essentially indistinguishable from a
native experience let's start at the
beginning of this story though bookmarks
are the original way for users to get
back to anywhere on the web they wanted
to get back to they're kind of a
universal install button and they've
been available in every major browser
since the dawn of the web so a good
question would be why don't we just use
that and in a word the answer is mobile
of course you can bookmark on mobile but
it never really fully made the jump and
we do see significantly less bookmark
usage on mobile that we see on desktop
one reason for that is that the UI it
just isn't quite as convenient and
that's not just saving the bookmarks
it's also organizing and finding them as
well
the second challenge that we see for
bookmarks on mobile is that apps as we
just saw right now integrated to the
mobile OS in ways that are important for
functionality so for example a lot of
apps do need to tie in to say androids
native sharing sheet which is what you
see on the right side of the slide where
URL is shared from the Metra PWA to
twitter and to enable a share target we
needed os-level entity we need something
like an apk on android and not just a
bookmark a lot of you will be familiar
with this term add to homescreen and
again you see that on the right and a
Starbucks screenshot of this example
unfortunately add to homescreen could
actually mean two different things it
could mean that it's a bookmark that's
being placed on the home screen or it
could also mean that it's actually an
integrated experience on the device and
that's why we'll be using the word
install for the rest of this talk to
talk about the integrated experience and
in the future you're going to see this
in the browser UI on mobile and desktop
the reason for that is install is a UX
affordance that's familiar to mobile
users who are used to adding content
from their OSS stores such as play and
then finding that content again on the
device through whatever the native
launch surfaces are so on mobile usually
from the home screen install aligns to a
user's mental model for how installed it
like basically how experiences ought to
operate on their device on
old web app looks and feels like every
other app and the fact that your user
discovered and installed your app from
the browser or from play shouldn't
actually matter when they go back to use
your app again most importantly the word
install signals to users that the
experience was meant to be great on
their device here's a summary of how web
install is different from bookmarks web
install offers users access to web apps
from familiar discovery and launch
surfaces for their device so it's all
wellness can be standalone that means
they can be separate from the browser it
also means that they can be integrated
into the native task switcher and they
could this could be a more familiar way
for users to interact with apps or it
might be more suitable to certain types
of tasks than tabs web install
integrates the web apps with the device
services that expect that installed out
the important thing to remember when
you're asking user to install a PWA is
that with it installed app you're
telling the user that it is an
experience that is meant for the device
that the user is using and that means
that you need to live up to those
expectations what you design your gonna
have unhappy users there's a good thing
that we have a pattern for building
experiences that do just that
progressive web apps our pattern for
great apps that use web technology and
they have all the features and
functionality users expect from a modern
app on mobile or desktop I'm sure most
of you in your room in this room are
quite familiar with POS at this point so
I'll just cover some of the very
high-level background information about
pwace for those of you who maybe are new
to the concept pedo you always include
things like personalized content offline
mode push notifications and instant
loading and pwace and install web apps
do go hand-in-hand you need to have a
PWA in order to offer install there are
of course other projects that are trying
to crack this problem and you can take a
look at a reactive at electron or
Cordova and all these are basically
offering you a way to build native apps
using web technology but those
experiences do depend on functionality
that won't also work in the web browser
pwace goal is to build directly on the
web so that means you can maintain one
code base and that's going to work for
visitors both in the browser as well as
for your installed users
so hi I'm lucky enough to get to work on
Santa tracker every year which is a fun
holiday themed experience for all ages
and so we'll be using this as an example
as we go along
Santa runs on basically everything or
with a browser even this magical screen
changing device and so we find that
folks will install it to their home
screens on any one of these platforms
where it's supported and some of our
most engaged users coming back the most
often and I'll enter it alone a few
years ago we found that about 10% of all
our loads were coming from that install
icon so that's a quite nice number this
is fundamentally because when an app is
installed you users will feel like it
it's designed for them users will have
better engagement more loyalty and have
a positive experience with different
with your installed application but of
course who are these users who is going
to benefit from this extra power we're
the first ones to admit that it won't be
everybody the power of the web has
always been that it is ephemeral users
can move seamlessly between experiences
and you so you shouldn't expect all of
your users to install and to where that
end there is a bit of an install funnel
this is the same as native apps or
e-commerce conversions most strategies
for optimization apply here as well you
don't want to push to use to convert too
soon or they'll leave your site running
you should only promote install to users
who are frequent users or who will
actually benefit from your services you
know focus on uses features that users
might care about like smaller download
size or faster access you'll also want
to track the right events and analytics
to make sure you know what to optimize
PJ will cover this a bit later on so
promote web install on screens where the
use case makes sense including desktop
tablet and mobile take this example of
Spotify as CTA from a landing page will
be also be covering more of these as we
go along so we've covered some of the
what and some of the why and I'll
continue now by talking about the how of
install your basic requirements for
supporting the installable web and I
have both our web app manifest and a
serviceworker these are actually in 2019
pretty well documented these are the
same requirements as we mentioned to be
called a PWA I'll mostly be covering the
manifest for the serviceworker just
briefly the requirement is that you do
actually load offline if you user clicks
on your app icon while they're offline
and they see nothing or an offline
diner users will have a bad time and so
will not install it in this case I think
you'll find some great amazing content
my code lies for Google on service
workers online oops the manifest is a
simple JSON file which basically informs
your user how the site acts when it's
installed you need one per app and you
need to include a link to it from every
page of your site so the user can tap
install anywhere and I'm kind of
trivializing it but pretty much all
modern browsers have some level of
support for this file and including it's
quite simple you simply include a link
in pretty much all your pages as I
mentioned because you don't know where
your user will hit install from one of
its core parts is controlling what your
launcher icon will actually look like
and the start page that opens when you
press it here's what an Android
experience will be Santa tracker has a
little green icon with a short name and
you'll see something quite similar when
an app is installed on desktop the
manifest also controls how your app is
loaded for games you might choose
fullscreen see the example on the right
but for anything app like you want
standalone which doesn't which won't
take over the target devices UI web
starts running in any mode can still use
browsers api's to relate a request
fullscreen there's a few other options
here including browser which retains the
URL bar but honestly we don't think this
is that interesting and so we think
these two options are what most people
will end up choosing when they configure
their installed PWA the manifest itself
is pretty boring
here it is for completeness I won't go
through every field like I said it's
actually tons of information out there
on the web but I want to cover some
important patterns you need to include a
few icons including one which is at
least 512 by 512 and remember that this
isn't your site's favicon so you still
need to include one of those in building
Santa tracker one thing we really
discovered was that there's no implicit
in internationalization support you need
to serve a different manifest for every
language and our icons the standard also
note describes mascot icons the very
short version is if you provide an icon
and indicate that its masker ball this
is a signal to the platform that it can
cut your icon down to safely display
crazy icon types like circles square
circles or teardrops making your users
feel like the app was really
for them and with this we actually
recommend not using transparency in your
PW icons at all because the OS is
handling this part for you of course
this is still a bit brand new so we
recommend also loading up your app in
some major environments to check what
the icon will look like there's a few
more things coming in to manifest which
are also worth mentioning app shortcuts
have just been added to the spec this
lets an install icon provide secondary
and tete intents perhaps through one
press I've kind of treated here and
shown you an Android example of this
case and web share target which we'll
cover more allows an install a web app
to be a target for sharing we're also
just seeing a bunch of tooling around
manifests and we think that honestly
going forward knowing every nearly every
tool chain you just provide you a web
app manifest and so while we're glad
you're listening this stuff is also
becoming just boring enough that it's
likely handled for you which is great
for us as web developers so as I
mentioned earlier manifests are
supported by pretty much all modern
browsers which leads me on to well the
nuances a web developers best friend
let's start with Android this was the
first place that installed was available
and once installed apps are first class
citizens provided by real native apks
importantly chrome on Android is
actually able to prompt your users to
install if your site includes a
serviceworker and a manifest Santa
tracker here is actually pretty
ambitious if you take a look at this
animation even during the loading screen
it pops up a little mini info bar it's
not ideal but we'll revisit this in a
bit regardless if you then tap that info
bar you'll get a full screen prompt to
install there's a few things that are to
dissect here while this does say at the
home screen as we mentioned we're moving
away from that verbage as we support
really so many platforms now and as I
mentioned this generates a real apk that
works with any launcher and is really a
first-class citizen for users like any
other installed application another
option for install on Android is
something called trusted web activities
or TBWA
well this has a few details to get
through fundamentally you're writing an
Android application which features a
core activity provided by Chrome or
actually fairly soon Firefox as well and
you're uploading it to the Play Store so
its discoverable and promotable like any
other native app the best way to learn
more here is to be go to go and follow
Google Google's code
on this do a search for tear beware code
labs to find out more we've also got an
interesting option for folks who are
using manage play with G suite this is
means if your organization signs into
corporate Gmail on their devices you can
simply push real apks that load your
your website by a managed play there's
quite a few steps this video is quite
long but if you're quite watch closely
here I've built Santa tracker for work
which pushes Santa tracker to all the
elves in Santa's org so while we think
this is really interesting it's also
worth noting that your corporate users
will actually never see the URL that's
being added to their device you're able
to push any web size in real app not
just your own finally and probably most
interestingly let's talk about the how
on iOS iOS has had installable web apps
since the beginning but the last few
releases have really made install an iOS
quite practical here's an example of
loading Santa tracker from the iPad we
do have to have custom icons this is
done by the iOS Meditec like on tags
which I won't really cover here and
while they're a bit of a pain tolling
can help you generate these alcohols
also previously suggested providing
splash screens honestly we don't even
think this is that important in anymore
iOS 13 has brought you nice animations
and fades that make sure that your
website isn't just daringly dumped on
the screen we didn't wanna use one in
this example and last but not least I
also want to talk about desktop only
chrome provides install and desktop
right now but it works well across all
platforms Mac OS Linux Chrome OS and
Windows your sites will get this little
plus button and users will get a native
app that lives in their launcher the
plaza button will even wiggle a little
bit if you do the right thing calling
attention to the fact that install is
available thanks Sam I'd like to cover
some of the frequently missed details
that will help you acquire more
installed users so first a lot of
companies have native apps and worry
about accidentally promoting the PWA to
a user who already has their app and you
may want to promote your PWA but you
want to especially target a group people
that are not your native app users now
keep in mind that there's all kinds of
reasons that a user may not have or want
your native app but might still want the
web app storage for example is the
number one reason that users remove apps
from their device but most web apps are
tiny and the
stores that most web apps use can be
dynamically purged from the browser
through either a manual cache clear or
in response to storage pressure so you
may want to let users know that the web
app option exists but you don't want to
create any channel conflict with your
native apps
so to avoid promoting your PWA install
feature to native app users you want to
use the get installed related apps just
there to help this API is going to let
you see in JavaScript if the user has
your native app installed Ganesan
related apps is not in stable yet but it
is in an origin trial which is an early
access program you can still use it on
your site today an order trial might
sound scary but all it means is that you
need to register online at the API will
be enabled for all chrome visitors to
your site probably there was some search
engine that will help you with that
only most PWA installs today are
happening from the mini info bar the
mini info bar was only intended as a
temporary shim it's not the best user
experience and since it's generated by
the browser it really has no way of
knowing whether this particular moment
is the right moment to present to the
user the option to install it just shows
up as soon as the site passes install
ability criteria and a user engagement
measure you're gonna want to replace the
mini info bar with something better but
and we're gonna get to what is better
than me oh for soon but first you need
to hide it and make sure that menu info
bar doesn't appear if you don't want it
and all you need to do that is to call
prevent default on the before install
prompt event make sure that you've added
the UI that you need to trigger the
install prompt before you do this though
or you will literally have no installed
users after you prevent default on this
so let's look at the code for a second
the relevant line is right here event
I'll prevent default and that's the
critical thing for hiding the minion
foot bar most sites it should be very
trivial change so let's assume that
you've got a UI element in the page
called install button and that you're
gonna want to display this install
button as soon as the browser signals
that your app can be installed you don't
want to show this beforehand because
this button won't work the way that the
user would expect
to work this element should be hidden
and then enabled and that's exactly what
we do in this next line and finally
you're gonna want to capture a reference
to the install event so that you can use
it to prompt the user later when the
user actually clicks on that install
button and now we can look at exactly
how you do that so here's how you use
that saved reference so let's imagine
that you want to wait until the user has
finished some important journey that's
part of your experience before you
prompt them you can use this stored
handle for whenever you're ready or the
user clicks on the install button in
your UI to trigger the browser's UI for
the install prompt don't forget to
instrument analytics so that you can
understand your users behavior with
respect to install prompts there's
really three important moments that you
want to capture here if your analytics
so the first is when that prompt is
actually available when did the site
fulfill the install ability criteria and
that happens with the before install
prompt event and that's what you listen
for and you can set up an analytics
event there the second is the analytics
for when the prompt is triggered if
you're taking the recommended approach
here and you're tying that to piece of
UI inside of your inside of your web
content then this is going to be
probably a click Handler on some element
inside of your page and finally when the
user has actually completed the OP
install you're gonna want to listen for
the app installed event and this is
what's going to tell you that the app
install was completed successfully
and the user hit OK from the browser UI
so you may be asking yourself what about
iOS and the great news here is that Iowa
Safari has had support for the essential
PW ingredient serviceworker for quite a
while now and it's easier than ever to
install PWS from iowa safari with Add to
Home screen like moving to an option in
the first-level menu so here's an
install promotional pattern for iOS that
we're going to use for Santa tracker
notice how this we're basically
triggering a pop-up helper to help the
user through the install experience from
the install button and this is the same
install button that we're going to use
on Android
well so the Delta between the two
experience is is really quite small so
with that owner told briefly about a few
different UX patents for your installed
PW A's so Santa truck is pretty unique
right it already has a pretty simple can
feel and you also probably doesn't it
looks like regular webpage so the
uncanny valley
the uncanny valley he refers to
something which looks almost correct
which is ultimately just a bit off like
this almost right Dino a game with some
very odd UI elements if your experience
doesn't match your expectation they
might be put off so we're Google of the
web and there's now an expectation that
perhaps an installed app acts and feels
like it's always been that way and this
advice isn't really unique to PW A's I
want to talk about the feeling we get
when we use web apps like Gmail Spotify
or even Google Docs when I use these
apps I almost forget that I'm on the web
how can you help your users have that
same level of emotion there's a few tips
I'd like to talk through to make your
site feel more native and then lose that
uncanny feeling focus rings where I'm
gonna start these like a user know where
the cursor is pretty basic access
accessibility feature which you should
keep but the default ring is a definite
tail with the web so mix it up and this
applies to form elements as well as
links text selection is also probably
something you want to disable especially
on UI components because it's not an
expected behavior of installed
applications personally I'm not ever a
fan of making this UI part of a page
selector ball but it's especially
pronounced when installed and set a
theme color this refers to the window
color of your app as you see in this
desktop version of Santa Tracker where
it's a dark blue by default is from the
platform so you don't really know what
you're gonna get and over scroll which
you can see happening here is actually
somewhat related because I don't mean
that three contrasting colors end up
showing and in most cases you'll just
want to disable over scroll from to
prevent this from happening
it's a very web pattern as an
alternative at least make sure that your
HTML tag is set to a reasonable
background color that's not the default
white also very briefly mentioned safe
area inset which if you're a fan of
nachos on phones lets you avoid that
knotch and put some color or interesting
some content behind that area you'll
also want to think about if some you are
us changes
I mean I'm gonna go through these fairly
quickly first don't allow navigation
outside your own sight if you do users
will get a really ugly URL bar make sure
you over always open external content in
a new window next think about better
behavior for extended actions like
select all undo and redo especially if
your experience is app like but my
default undo and redo only apply to text
elements what if you're allowing a user
to reorder a list and finally you might
want to do something different with the
right-click menu especially when
installed on desktop the default menu
includes items like save as or cast
which barely makes sense on some web
pages and while it's bad practice
practice to disable this right-click
menu on the web when you're installed
there's really a license to improve the
use excusing experience by hiding these
options so I've mentioned a couple of
times the different ways that you can
promote your web app and here's where we
get into the examples of how exactly to
do it so keep in mind as we go through
these that these patterns aren't
intended for every kind of site they're
examples of good patterns that you can
use but try to understand your use cases
and use patterns that are appropriate
for you and please always remember the
rule of thumb whenever you're prompting
users about anything install or
otherwise don't be annoying let's give
this a try alright first the header can
be a good place to produce all of your
app but you do need to be careful here
this one comes with a lot of cautions
and hand waves these are really precious
pixels and you want to use information
architecture and a/b testing to
determine whether it actually makes
sense for you to have an install option
and a header of your site for some apps
this will be a clear and obvious win and
for other apps it would be completely
inappropriate that will really depend on
your use case you may want to use an
icon instead of text if you want to make
this action button a little bit smaller
and you might also want to consider
selectively promoting only to users that
have engaged with you so for example
could be only shown to signed-in users
who clearly have an interest in what the
product or service that you're offering
this is an example of adding an install
prompt to the hamburger menu the great
thing about using the menu here
for promoting your web app install is
that there's already a strong signal
that the user is interested in what
you're offering by clicking on the menu
and I hope that this is obvious but you
don't want to block access to any
important functionality in your app with
the promotion here or anywhere else for
that matter you don't want to make sure
that it doesn't overlay anything or
clutter up the menu design or in any way
take precedence over the other actions
that the user might want to take by
clicking on that menu here's an example
of promoting install via a landing page
and landing pages are explicitly about
marketing your product or service and so
this is really your one opportunity to
you know go crazy be as big as you want
but just keep in mind that all the usual
best practices for creating a good
landing page are going to apply here in
particular the most essential thing
about your landing page is that the user
understands what the value proposition
that you're offering them is if your
install pattern is getting in the way of
that then chances are you're going to
lose both the potential user and you're
certainly not going to encourage them to
actually install here's an example of an
in feed pattern for promoting PWA
install and fee cards are very common
these days in many types of apps
including students social and news
ecommerce basically anywhere where
there's a lot of virtual or vertical
scrolling and chunked information don't
show this promotion too often and if a
user dismisses the card please to
remember and respect the users choices
here every apps use case is a little bit
different but there's almost always some
key moment of engagement in the journey
when you know that the user is truly
interested and understands what it is
that you're offering and that's a great
moment to ask if they want to reconnect
with you in the near future the usual
rules apply here you want to always
focus on the benefit to the user and use
the context of the key moment in this
example the users just finished a game
it's a great opportunity to say hey do
you want to play again really easily you
can find this again from your home
screen so let's recap on the principles
here don't be annoying your users came
to your site to get something done
if you interrupt that flow or make it it
anyway difficult for them to get the
task done that they came to your site
for chances are they're just gonna leave
and go get it done somewhere else
information architecture is your friend
for figuring out what belongs where and
that includes for promoting install
second remember that if the user doesn't
benefit you shouldn't be promoting it
and finally do use the context where is
the user in their journey to help the
user understand what they're actually
going to get out of installing your app
if you want to learn more you can search
through the fundamental site with a
query promoting install now investing in
a great PWA and making that pwe
installable does have big benefits for
user engagement to talk about these
benefits in practice
Mukunda product manager for oil consumer
experience is going to join us on stage
and talk about the impact install
ability has had for them and their team
as a little bit of background IO is the
world's second largest hotel chain and
it has a presence in more than 80
countries as more than 23,000 hotels and
with the rapid growth they have
basically pursued mobile web as a key
demand channel so today Makuta is going
to take you through all that's happened
with their mobile web experience and how
they've grown in the last year please
welcome with good
thank you Peter hi I am oaken I'm
product manager for yo-yo consumer
experience and I'm super excited and
delighted to share the journey or for
your mobile web as well as how focus on
this channel led to rich results for us
so if we talk about the growth that we
saw in our mobile web we can talk about
three major interventions that were
brought about first was PWA this was
followed by the capability as well as
adoption of browser installs finally the
integration of TWA the distrusted web
activities really led to raised results
for us with each of these key
interventions we were able to see good
sizeable lifts and conversion as well as
key capability increase also our product
was made more accessible to the
end-users let me take you through each
of these interventions one by one pwe
was the first major intervention for us
it provided users with key UX
capabilities like offline support
reliability on different networks which
was especially important for us given
the markets we were present in and also
better latency overall we saw a
conversion left of around 2.2 X while
our user base also rose by 4x we saw a
latency rise of almost 75% our product
was optimized leaps and bounds and this
was one of the first major breakthroughs
which really made us belief in our
mobile web with an already optimized
product in our hands we were looking to
make it more and more accessible to the
end-users this is where the capability
of browser installs came into the
picture from browser installed users
were already converting by around 2x as
compared to PWA having these metrics
inside we were actually looking to
increase its adoption this is where we
started doing a lot of
maybe experiments around how to have
images across you surgeons we started
making nudges on home pages and host
booking pages in which we saw adoption
increase of around 1.5 X whereas we did
not see any drop in PWA conversion
finally this may be released oil light
which was built on trusted web activity
it was a major breakthrough in the world
of our mobile web users were starting to
get access to a opw a on Play Store
which was really cool the number since
have been incredible we have a similar
rating on oil light as compared to
native app this showcases the importance
of core capabilities like low size easy
over-the-air updates deep linking
support fullscreen and a lot of other
capabilities overall we were seeing a
conversion lift of 3 X as compared to
PWM and our conversion was similar to
the native apt to summarize each of
these interventions has brought about a
good growth in our channel from M site
to twe our conversion has rising by
around 6 point 6 X which is incredible
mobile lab has been the highest growing
demand channel for oil over the past few
months and we have undoubtedly benefited
from all the 3 interventions and got a
great ROI out of it
thank you
thanks so much everyone just to invite
you to come on by the sandbox will be
there most of the day tomorrow our
twitter handles are right up here so do
please reach out to us if you have any
questions any feedback or you know feel
like a good public shaming
you